so it's obviously no secret that we like
to tell a couple blue jokes some sex
jokes I like to say the word but
occasionally on the show we like to
cleanse our palate by doing this this is
a segment that we I think everybody can
enjoy so ladies and gentlemen please
enjoy a nice boy telling nice jokes
my teacher said I'm her favorite student
to give detention too drunk be jealous I
made this whole crowd laugh about being
filthy how do you catch a butterfly
online you use an Internet no solid gold
right there right did did the toggle led
Kentucky with me kids
that's your sleazebag Creek and you know
it you know I went to my school dance
last week there's one dance move I
really enjoy it's called sitting down
you're a hack rat that's what you are
all right do you know that don't look at
me like that
all right I try to come here and class
up your garbage dump of a show okay
there is more class in a disease pigeons
[ __ ]
then your entire [ __ ] body man all
right you watch and learn mother here's
an impression of my mom cooking a meal
for the family one large pizza please hi
I don't don't you alright
you shut your snake mouth okay your
forked tongue cold-blooded all right
what happens if I poke you you've
shipped old Doughboy huh just gonna come
out what's gonna come out diary out of
your mouth that was gonna happen
what you can resist me football bag you
had a bottle on you the whole time
that's nice boys roll
why did we rebook you you sit there you
shut the up and let me do my thing okay
sorry
thanks everyone good night